hey guys it's justine and i'm so excited
because today not only am i in one of my
most favorite places in the world i'm in
hawaii i have two new devices here i
have the samsung galaxy z fold three and
the samsung galaxy z flip three and for
those of you that don't know the flip
phone is one of my most favorite android
devices of all time there is just
something so special about it just the
way that you're able to flip it open i
love the screen i love everything about
it and a lot of these small complaints
and issues that people have had of the
previous versions hopefully have been
resolved in this new one so let's unbox
and check them out maybe i'll take a
little step back from
this dock
because i don't trust myself
i think i'm far enough away from the
water that i feel confident that i can
open this safely without getting it
anywhere near the ocean so let's start
with the z-fold
look at this oh man i'm so excited i
wonder what color it is
it's the phantom black so this comes in
three different colors this the phantom
black the phantom silver and the phantom
green i think i'm probably gonna
purchase for myself the phantom silver
although
this matte black does look pretty nice
oh man
the first fold
that's slippery
so the thing that i'm most excited about
testing out with this is the under
display camera and that's going to be
the answer to basically getting rid of
the notch so obviously when the device
is off you can see where the camera is
but in the demo that i saw when they
announced this phone you could barely
see it at all when the screen is
actually on let's see what else is in
the box okay well i guess uh you saw
that first so the z-fold 3 now has s-pen
support and it has a bunch of various
views that you can use with standard
view multi-view to make multi-tasking
even more efficient it has a new task
bar and have access to the things that
you need the most as quick as possible
this has 120 hertz dynamic amoled 2x 7.6
inch infinity flex display with that
really cool under display camera it has
12 gigs of ram and you could choose
between 512 gigs or 256 gig storage
options it has a 4 400 milliamp hour
battery and yes it does have a
fingerprint sensor it has a 12 megapixel
ultra wide wide and telephoto and the
hidden cover camera is 10 megapixels i
love that they're calling this an
uninterrupted display so the display is
completely seamless and not interrupted
by the notch the camera is nicely hidden
right under here now it's time for the z
flip oh this thing is so cool i also
love all the little accessories that
they have for them now what color is it
going to be what color is it going to be
oh it's the cream oh this actually looks
really good
so
satisfying um hi can i order some pizza
please let's be real i don't actually
talk on my phone i like that they have a
larger front display this is going to be
so much better for actually reading
notifications you'll also be able to get
a larger view if you are taking a photo
or you know taking a selfie so this
little guy has an infinity flex display
it's 6.7 inches full hd dynamic amoled
2x the cover display is a 1.9 inch super
amoled this is 8 gigs of ram and you can
choose between 256 and 128 gig options
for storage and it has a 3 300 milliamp
battery the thing that i like about this
hinge now is it has a free stop angle so
you can kind of
basically make this stop anywhere so the
hinge is way more
let's just say more flexible like it's
more flexible but it's more flexible to
you whereas you can do more things and
make it stop at any angle which is so
cool so this does have three cameras
there's two on the front we have a 12
megapixel wide and ultra wide and the
front facing camera is 10 megapixels for
the one that i'm gonna purchase i'm
going to definitely be getting the
lavender it actually would match my
hoodie
so it's actually kind of cool because
samsung was able to reduce these in
price so the z flip is starting at 9.99
and dz fold is starting at 17.99 now yes
that is still pretty expensive for
smartphones but i feel like for a
flagship foldable that's a pretty
competitive price and man i'm so excited
to test these out there it is there it
is there it is yes yes yes yes so this
is kind of my first time seeing the
under display camera it's so weird
because really the only way to kind of
explain what i'm seeing is it looks like
it's just like the camera hole is all
lit up like i can see it like if i don't
look directly at the camera hole i can't
see it but if i look at it like i see it
but like i don't see it am i doing a bad
job of explaining it
see look you can see it but like you
can't see it thank you guys so much for
watching this quick look at these i do
plan on doing a further review i am
traveling and i am filming something
really fun here so hopefully i can get
this review out soon but i cannot wait
to check these out samsung is doing such
an incredible job with these devices and
now that this is like the third edition
i can only imagine that they're gonna be
that much better i would love to hear
from you guys so in the comments below
let me know what you guys think of these
devices are you excited about it do you
have one did you pre-order one i would
love to hear it and if you haven't
already please subscribe and hit the
bell so you'll be notified when i post
new videos and i cannot wait to check
these out further so until then i will
see you guys later and i'll see you in
the comments
[Music]